This was the center of Marawi.
Today, residents call it "ground zero".
We get the military's permission to enter
selected parts and are warned about unexploded
devices.
Last year a few hundred 'IS'-inspired fighters
holed up in mosques and houses.
The army, with help from the US, responded
with relentless air raids.
In this type of warfare you have to flush
out the enemy from their defensive position
and you can only do that Number 1 using bombs
or heavy artillery bombardment.
If you look at the experience of Mosul, Raqqa
and Aleppo, all of these experienced bombings.
But in the case of Marawi City, when we did
the bombings, we did it pinpointed to specific
targets only.
But people here paid a very high price for
the 5-month-long battle.
Hundreds were killed.
They're buried in these mass graves.
Most of the victims were never identified,
denying their families closure.
Over 65,000 people remain displaced.
Many are still searching for their loved ones.
Fatima has lost four of her eight children.
She believes they were taken hostage and used
as human shields.
I feel a very deep pain inside of me.
I miss my children.
They were gone in a blink of an eye.
I can't be with them any more.
It hurts, because I can still feel them and
hear them.
In the suburbs, life is slowly returning to
normal, but the biggest Muslim city in the
Philippines has been changed forever.
Martial law remains in force, with soldiers
everywhere.
The impoverished region has witnessed decades
of conflict between Muslims and Christians
who make up the vast majority of the Filipino
population.
Many young Muslims feel disenfranchised.
Last year Abdul spied on the military, passing
on details of troop movements to 'IS' fighters
holed up in Marawi.
He tells us that he's still ready to fight
for an Islamic state.
We have an advantage because we just blend
in.
The military cannot easily identify us as
fighters who know how to use a gun.
I would not fight in Marawi again, or in any
other Muslim area here.
Then the same thing will happen again.
Our own Muslim people would get hurt.
But if the battle happens elsewhere, I will
join.
Like many others, Abdul blames President Duterte
for bombing Marawi.
The government has promised reconstruction
and greater Muslim autonomy.
But until those promises are fulfilled, angry
young men like Abdul continue to pose
a threat.